the next play after that the fourth down  you know they run into like they run  into each other you know I'm not a  receiver like I think I like to think  I'm a Rob receiver but I saw Devonte  going inside he's probably supposed to  take an outside release I was thinking  that cuz it's either he was supposed to  take an outside release or Hunter Renfro  wasn't supposed to go outside because  they was what we call pissing in the  same Coke bottle yeah and that's why  they ran into each other because he had  a corner he had a post you don't know in  my in my mind K might have been right  and then I don't know it looked like  that car he threw it it looks like he  threw the post he was throwing the post  to Devonte in the middle of the field  yeah so he was he was imagining them  being there